hi I'm Eric Voss and with the Walking
Dead Season eight coming soon AMC just
released a sneak peak scene from the
season premiere along with some major
details from the cast and writers and
after spending all summer making fan art
work let's break this all down and make
some big predictions for season 8 and
sure you could just read the comics to
get a sense of where the show is going
but judging from past seasons the show
has gone in very different directions
before also last season pulled bits and
pieces of events that occur in very
different points of the timeline in the
comics so I'm gonna stick mostly to
what's happened in the show and footage
that we've seen so let's start with a
sneak peak scene that was just released
here's the gist maggie rick is zekiel
jesus and gabriel meet up before what
looks like an attack against negan
maggie jokes about fighting a war while
pregnant Ezekiel offers to let Maggie
use his doctor at the kingdom but Jesus
promises to get the hilltops doctor back
then Rick and Maggie talk about tomorrow
hinting at the idea of a peaceful
retirement after the war is won and Rick
tells Maggie that he wants to follow her
someday as a leader then we cut to a
short scene showing Carol Daryl Terrell
and Morgul who on an overpass with Tara
timing the arrival of a walker horde so
there's some key clues here first notice
the metal sheeting on the cars and
trucks behind Rick and Maggie also check
out all those color-coded armbands that
they're wearing combined with what Tara
and the others are doing and clues from
the trailer that I broke down already we
started to piece together what's going
on here writers on the show said that
season 8 will pick up the action from
the end of season 7 and move at a
breakneck speed lighting a fuse that
will lead to an explosion at the end of
the episode so here's my first
prediction
I think the season premiere will include
a follow-up attack on the sanctuary the
forces of Alexandria the hilltop and the
kingdom will join forces wearing
different colored armbands to
distinguish themselves by colony white
for Alexandria green for the hilltop and
red for the kingdom to signal to each
other where they're from and that they
aren't saviors and then this side crew
will lure in a horde of walkers while
the rest of the group uses these shield
cars to box in those walkers around the
sanctuary trapping negan and the
Savior's the way Rick's people were
trapped in season six now I'll say I
think that's the plan but we'll see if
it goes down that way there was that one
reaction from Aaron
the trailer that made it seem like some
people will want to go beyond the scope
of the plan oh I'm gonna make a second
prediction here I think this assault
will end with some people getting
captured specifically Gabriel the sneak
peak scene included this choice
concerned reaction shot from Gabriel
while everyone else seems so confident
also we know from the trailer that
Gabriel does end up in a room with negan
at some point I hope you got your
[ __ ] pants on well you should
actually that line is a direct quote
from negan in the comics right after the
sanctuary is going through a similar
situation and that might explain why
Walker's appear to be pounding on the
windows behind negan in the scene
actually speaking of negan and Gabriel
here the writers hinted at this moment
is going to have religious undertones
it's gonna feel like a kind of a start
of a confession for me again so that
brings me to my next prediction we are
gonna learn parts of Meghan's backstory
in season 8 so throughout this storyline
in the comics Megan's backstory remained
a mystery until recently when Robert
Kirkman released special issues that
explained his origin I won't get into
exactly what it was here but the writers
have said they intend to bring elements
of those comics in to negan story on the
show now while I don't think we'll get
full flashbacks showing Meegan's life
before their zombie apocalypse like the
series has only rarely jumped out of the
present I do think we'll get bits and
pieces of negan telling other characters
about his past for example with Gabriel
here and different Morgan said Eugene
will end up being a key confidant a
character for him so I think we should
expect something like Tom Hanks's
character in Saving Private Ryan whose
job before the war was a mystery that
all the other soldiers bet on until he
revealed it to stop the infighting to
pull on me up to right now I'm a school
teacher I teach English Composition now
I should say that even though the show
has historically been more careful about
jumping away from the present I think
that does actually explain what we saw
at the end of the trailer with old man
Rick waking up in bed despite the fan
theories the writers have confirmed that
this is not Rick waking up from his coma
in season 1 but all the events of The
Walking Dead being Rick's dream without
spoiling anything from the comics I'm
gonna make another prediction here I
think this old man Rick scene will be a
I'm the literal daydream or a good
old-fashioned night dream of Riggs ideal
hopes for retirement after the war this
is the tomorrow that he and Maggie were
referring to in that sneak peak scene
remember in the season premiere of last
season after Glenn and Abraham's death
Rick experienced a surreal vision of the
heavenly future that he imagined sharing
with all of his friends I think this old
man Rick shot is something similar a
dream scenario the chance to grow old
that will inspire Rick to keep fighting
now I know some of you are saying this
could be a time jump but they haven't
even started shooting the second half of
the season yet and I don't think they're
gonna end this war with negan so quickly
instead I think the show is gonna give
us this one out of chronology vision and
leave it as a mystery how the president
events might lead to it now I know for a
lot of you when you first saw it this
shot had some morbid tones to it like it
could be foreshadowing Rick's death and
this is heaven that he's waking up and I
don't have obviously I don't think Rick
is gonna die this is obviously his story
and Andrew Lincoln has signed on to play
the role of brick through the end of
season nine at least but the season 8
trailer did hint that he would be
captured this season by the scavengers
and I think this imprisonment might be
where he sees this old maverick vision
but Rick is probably safe instead let's
make some predictions about who will die
I think this season will show us the
death of Morgan in the trailer he had
this noticeable line on old eye which
seems like exactly the kind of thing a
character in The Walking Dead would say
before a walker lunges on them Lennie
James actually joked about this with
Chris Hardwick on the talking dead what
Morgan's line I don't die I don't die in
the trailer what is what it what it what
is your reaction to that well it's not
sorry Matt it doesn't matter what my
reaction to is the fans reaction and my
kids reaction is daddy does that mean
you're dead now the season 8 premiere
will be these show's 100th episode which
is a major milestone that they plan to
celebrate with a bunch of visual
callbacks through season 1 some of which
we've seen in the trailer and I really
think a dramatic goodbye to one of the
few characters from that pilot episode
could be how the show plans to do that
the writers did say that while the first
three episodes will feature non-stop
action things do slow down to be more
acoustic after that so maybe a shocking
early in the season death is what
triggers that emotional slow
now when we talk about other characters
who might die I think people like Maggie
are probably safe they actually said
that Maggie is still not gonna deliver
her baby in season eight so I think our
characters in this for the long haul
along with Pam favorites like Daryl
Carol coral unmarked uh-huh they're
probably safe too
that said now that we're in all-out war
we're probably gonna see some major
casualties and I predict that those
casualties will be a lot worse on team
Rick's side than the Savior's for
example I could see characters like
Simon or Jada Stein in season eight but
really if I'm putting money down I
wouldn't feel too great about characters
like Rosita Jerri Erin's boyfriend Eric
and Shiva now why those four well Rosita
has had a death wish since Abraham died
she probably feels like it was her who
should have died not Sasha so I can see
her following in Sasha's footsteps also
remember Jerry had that ominous line to
Ezekiel in the trailer thank you your
majesty what for being such a cool dude
yeah kind of stuff like famous last
words of everyone's favorite new
characters also let's be honest Eric
started to get way too involved last
season for a minor character that
normally we would never think about and
yes Shiva is exactly the game-changing
threat that negan would probably target
first or you know maybe the season will
end with the walkers turning Shiva into
a zombie tiger and riding her through
the wall yeah kind of like on Game of
Thrones at the dragon I mean come on
they're kind of turning into the same
show right
another character that I would be
surprised to see make it out of this
season alive is Gregory from the hilltop
Gregory was kind of a loose end last
season like we last saw him as he
prepared to make contact with negan most
likely to make some kind of side deal to
protect his interest at the hilltop but
considering maggie has positioned
herself as the leader of hearts and
minds of these farmers with pitchforks
and spears Gregory has become a man
without an army and in an all-out war
the players without any real backing or
real power tend to die off pretty
quickly now one last prediction I want
to make before I go I think season 8
will hint maybe in the subtlest of hints
at the emergence of the whispers now I'm
about to go into something from a later
point in the comics so if you haven't
read them and you don't want to know
skip to this time cool go
the whisperers are a new rival group who
show up long after the war against negan
they skin walkers and where they're
rotting flesh over their bodies posing
as walkers themselves that are called
whisperers because they whisper human
words to each other it scares the crap
out of other humans who wonder how
Walker's are able to talk now you can
read the comics to learn all about the
interesting ways they come into the
story and while nothing we've seen has
indicated to me that this is gonna
happen and I think it's still a little
too soon for them to start influencing
these events I think by the end of the
season there will be some tease of these
guys coming into the picture
I'm just saying all these actors are
getting older and while many of them
have signed on through a ninth season
and the rest are happy to have a gig
like The Walking Dead I think the show
is gonna want to bring in the cooler
elements from the comics before too long
who do you think is the most likely to
die in season 8 which characters are
gonna be the most frustrating as they
change loyalties and who do you thinks
gonna be the most fun to watch I mean
it's gonna be Carol right Carol is Carol
again this is great let me know your
thoughts in the comments below or hit me
up on Twitter a TA boss or new rock
stars at new rock stars and share this
video and subscribe to new rock stars
for more Walking Dead videos make sure
to check out my breakdown of the season
8 trailer if you haven't already and if
you really like this channel you can
contribute to us on patreon and our
patreon team members help us decide what
type of videos to make and we're
currently thinking of alternate ways to
cover season 8 of The Walking Dead
beyond the breakdowns like Theory videos
instant reactions Q&A s as we get closer
to season 8 we'd love to know what kind
of videos you'd like to see us make
about it and you can help us decide by
contributing to us on patreon
big thanks to all of our current donors
especially Allen Fleming okay thanks for
watching bye